[MUSIC PLAYING]
LINO CATTARUZZI: OK,
so let's get started.
This is special.
We will talk, in
particular for me.
I want to introduce
you to Loic de Kerdrel.
Loic is a very good friend.
I'm going to make
a disclaimer first.
Actually, he's my
marriage witness.
And we've known each
other for 16 years?
LOIC DE KERDREL: Yeah.
LINO CATTARUZZI: Roughly.
I'm not going to give all
the details on how we me
each other.
So don't worry.
We met in Argentina on 31st
of December in a party.
And we have many
friends in common.
And then we grew over
time on our friendship.
And now I wanted him to
share a little bit with you
his track record,
what he has done
in business, and
of course, share
some advices and things to you.
So Loic, I would
really like to start.
First, thank you
for making the time
and coming here and joining us.
And second, do you mind sharing
a little bit of who you are
and what is the
company you created?
LOIC DE KERDREL: OK,
hello to everybody.
I apologize.
My English isn't perfect.
But I will do my best.
LINO CATTARUZZI: If
not, you say in French.
Most of them understand.
LOIC DE KERDREL: OK.
No, I will try in English.
I like challenges.
Thank you, Lino,
to invite me here.
I was supposed to be on holiday
with my family for a week.
But Lino wants me back
to work, apparently.
No, I'm very happy to be here.
It's very interesting for me to
visit Google office to see the
how it works here.
And I'm very, very happy.
So roughly, I
created with a friend
a company called
Adverline in 1999.
So it's quite a long time ago.
LINO CATTARUZZI: You
were very, very young.
LOIC DE KERDREL: I
was very young then.
It was not my first job.
I had worked two years
before in a company
called ICI, Imperial Chemical
Industries-- so nothing in
common with technology.
But at that moment--
I don't know--
It was the beginning
of internet.
Everybody was
setting up companies.
So I was really getting
bored in this big company.
And I thinking, I should
dive into this new movement.
So first I joined a
startup who was copying
eBay, more or less, in France.
And it was sold rapidly
to another company.
So I decided to
create Adverline.
So we had an idea.
I had an idea it was that
every day lots of new websites
were created in France.
And most of them couldn't
make money, basically.
They were all dreaming
of making money.
But they were too small.
The audience was too small
to make money, basically.
So we thought, OK, if we could
gather all these audiences
together, it would
make a big audience.
And we could sell the
advertising space.
It was a very simple idea.
And at that time, Google
AdSense was not really here.
So--
LINO CATTARUZZI: Wait.
Somebody thought the idea
was good here as well there.
LOIC DE KERDREL: It
was maybe in the US.
But in France, AdSense
was not here at the time.
So we first started to
develop a technology to--
it was kind of an
ad-serving technology
that make it easy for a
webmaster to subscribe.
And I bought-- some advertising
pages in a geek magazines
with a very simple message.
It was, webmaster, subscribe
Adverline and make money.
And we had lots of success with
this very simple advertising
campaign.
Hundreds of websites
every week were
subscribing because they
had basically no solution
to make money.
LINO CATTARUZZI: And
that was year 2000, '99.
LOIC DE KERDREL: Yeah,
2000, I would say.
And so we were ready to--
we have the stock of
advertising space set.
So we started to sell it to
advertising agency, basically.
And the strategy was
to set a low price.
So we created a
microbilling solution
to enable this website,
some of these websites
to put a paywall,
basically, on the pages.
It was a very easy way
to create this paywall.
Yeah, very, very easy way.
LINO CATTARUZZI: So as money
and advertising disappear,
paywall was the solution
you came up with.
LOIC DE KERDREL: Yes, paywall,
but it was macrobilling.
So it was basically, you had
to dial a premium phone call.
You get a code.
You enter the code on the page.
And you get the content.
So it helped us to go through
these two years, 2001, 2002,
where the market was
very, very difficult.
And in 2003, when the
market started again,
we had no more competitor
on the advertising part.
They were all dead,
basically, in France.
That moment, it was
a very special moment
because the market started
to be really bullish.
And we had a very,
very strong growth.
And in some areas, we didn't
have enough space to sell.
So we thought, OK, we don't
So we're going to
create this space.
So we started creating space and
creating websites, basically.
And we became publishers
in [INAUDIBLE]..
But the first website
was Zone-ASDL.
It was a comparator--
LINO CATTARUZZI:
Price comparison site.
LOIC DE KERDREL: Yeah, price
comparison site for ISP
because we had
lots of advertisers
at that time who are fighting
for market shares in France.
And then, because we had
a very strong growth,
I met someone who proposed
me to make an IPO, basically.
It was really weird.
I met the guy.
He said, oh, you
should make an IPO.
Or really, how does it work?
I had no idea, basically.
Well, you always have
experts everywhere.
So he explained
me how it worked.
And we take-- people
who knew how it worked.
And one year after, we
were raised 15 million euro
through an IPO.
And basically, it was to
accelerate the movement
towards publishing
because at that moment,
Google was really
ready with AdSense.
And so the--
LINO CATTARUZZI:
That was 2007, 2008?
LOIC DE KERDREL:
No, it was 2006.
LINO CATTARUZZI: '06, OK.
LOIC DE KERDREL:
Our strategy, which
was to use the
long tail basically
of a website to put it back
in the advertising market.
Google wasn't on the cake.
We had to find out
quickly a new business.
So I thought being a master of
your website was the solution.
So we raised that money.
And we invested in
websites that were
some of were in our network.
We have a very strategic
vision of which websites were
accelerating more than others.
So we invested maybe
in 10 websites.
Sometimes, it was
a minority stake.
Sometimes it was
a majority stake.
We acquired societe.com.
I don't know if you know it.
In France, maison.com-- more
or less than 10 websites.
And we continued the
development until 2012.
And we sold the
company, actually,
to a French big group.
And I'm still CEO
of that company.
So it's now four, five
years after when I sold it.
I thought I would stay
two years and leave.
Finally, I'm still here.
I don't know how it comes.
But I'm still here.
LINO CATTARUZZI:
They still like you.
LOIC DE KERDREL:
Yeah, I don't know.
I--
[LAUGHTER]
LINO CATTARUZZI: They
maybe don't like you?
LOIC DE KERDREL: I don't know.
But I'm still here.
It was four years ago.
I got married.
I make three babies
in that time.
So I didn't waste my time.
LINO CATTARUZZI: I guess
it's not that common to--
[LAUGHTER]
LINO CATTARUZZI: I guess
it's not that common
that you find somebody with the
track record and the expertise.
So even if they wanted
to find somebody else,
I'm not sure will have the
competencies, experience,
and the insights.
LOIC DE KERDREL: Well,
it's a very big challenge
for big groups that don't have
the internet culture to-- when
they invest in smaller
startups like us,
it's very complicated
to integrate them.
That's a very big problem.
And I still don't know.
Me, really, I'm ready
to go, actually.
But I'm really scared of what
they would do with the company
after that.
I'm very attached to--
LINO CATTARUZZI:
More or less care.
You really care.
You really are attached.
LOIC DE KERDREL:
Yes, but I think
it's a very big
challenge for big groups
to integrate because they
have a process, big process.
And we are a very--
a giant company.
It's a very big challenge.
But part of independence,
you let to the company.
And if you don't
have the founder, who
will take the lead after it?
It's a bit complicated, I think.
It's not always easy.
LINO CATTARUZZI: So let me
ask you a couple of things
into the description
you did on Adverline.
Let's talk about
the tough moments
because it's 2000, 2001.
The stock market goes down.
There's no funding.
By the time, there was
not a lot of believe
into online advertising, right?
And then your main source--
or only source of revenues
goes away.
And then you come creatively
with another solution
that lets you survive.
What were the toughest moments?
And what did you learn?
LOIC DE KERDREL: Well, I think
the tough moments were first
the creation.
We did a business plan.
We went to see a
business analyst.
Very few people, even very
bright and smart people,
the best educated people,
but old generation,
probably like me now, they
said, but do you really
believe in this internet?
I mean, we had these
type of answers.
And it was really amazing.
So it was a bit tough because we
had to start it without money.
Then after the
second tough moment,
you said it was when
the bubble exploded.
And we had no more money.
And we had to find solutions.
And basically, we
were a small team.
We were maybe 12 people.
And we had to shrink to
six people, maybe, I guess.
We nearly didn't get
paid, me and my partner.
I slept in the office
room more than a year.
So it was really tough.
When I felt that the
market was starting again--
because we had two
business angels,
I thought, OK, I want now.
I'm ready to fight again.
But I don't want to fight for--
because we had lost the
majority of the company.
So I was not ready to
fight to suffer again
for less than the majority.
So I offered the
two business owners
to buy the shares for
basically the price I bought.
They bought them
price of 5% per year.
And they accepted.
So I sold my flat,
which was my only--
I had a small flat
in Montmartre.
I sold it to buy it.
And plus, I borrowed
a bit at the bank.
LINO CATTARUZZI: You
became homeless to buy
your own company.
LOIC DE KERDREL: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
LOIC DE KERDREL: Exactly.
But that was the time I slept
in the office, actually.
And--
LINO CATTARUZZI: Well,
that's consistent.
LOIC DE KERDREL: Yes.
But it was totally crazy.
I would never suggest
people to do that.
It was really crazy.
LINO CATTARUZZI:
And I don't think
your wife will appreciate if
you propose something like that.
LOIC DE KERDREL:
No, it was crazy.
But at the end of
the day, it was--
two years later, we went public.
So of course, the value
was not at all the same.
You can imagine the share.
But so it was crazy.
But it worked, actually.
That's how we went public.
And we had 100% of the
capital with my partner, which
is quite rare in our industry.
Most of the people
who go public,
they are already diluted by
many VCs and business angels,
and all this.
LINO CATTARUZZI: Well, you were.
It's just you had
the vision to trust.
And you trusted your business
so much that you bought again
your shares.
LOIC DE KERDREL: Yeah,
I think it was crazy.
And we were lucky, I think--
not only lucky but also lucky.
LINO CATTARUZZI: Yeah, the
more I work, the luckier I get.
LOIC DE KERDREL: I don't know,
but I wouldn't do it today,
I'm sure.
LINO CATTARUZZI: OK,
so I think that--
and I have some
inside information--
LOIC DE KERDREL: Yes, and just
to complete the tough moments,
as I said, the company
is a very tough moment
as well because you sell it.
And you don't know if
it's stupid or not.
Now I'm really happy to
have sold it, actually.
But it's a very tough
moment because you have to--
you have the
impression that you're
selling your son or something
that belongs to you.
LINO CATTARUZZI: It's emotional.
LOIC DE KERDREL: It's
very, very emotional.
It's a very hard moment.
Even if you basically
get money, OK, so you're
happy to get money.
And [INAUDIBLE]
says, so what now?
And it's a very, very tough
moment in terms of emotion.
LINO CATTARUZZI: So
let's for a second assume
that anyone here or
anyone watching the video
are going to start
their own company.
Would would be the
two or three advices
that you will give
them to make sure
that they maximize their
chance of being successful?
And I hope it's not
sell your apartment
to invest in your own company.
LOIC DE KERDREL: No, no.
Really, it's very hard to
give advices because me,
lots of people gave me very
bad advices, basically.
[LAUGHTER]
LOIC DE KERDREL: No, it's true.
Very smart people always
told me, OK, I know.
Your business plan is OK.
But you should wait two years.
The market is-- so I think
the advice would be not
to listen too much to advices.
[LAUGHTER]
LINO CATTARUZZI:
Except this one.
LOIC DE KERDREL: No, no,
and to follow your faith.
You really need to have the
faith in something, in an idea,
and you have to be really
willing to create your company.
If you're not really
ready, if you just
want to create your
company because it's
fashionable to create a
company, because it's cool,
you must be ready to suffer.
And if you really have a vision
and faith and a big will,
you will not feel the
bad moments, basically.
My advice is you have
to follow your idea.
Your idea must be strong, not
very smart, but very strong
in you.
My advice as well is
you have to take risks.
But so the sooner,
the better, I would
say because for example, me
today, I have three children.
I would not take the same risk.
It was not a problem for me to
sleep in my office two years.
I had nothing.
I had this little flat.
So if you fail,
it's not a big deal.
You fail, you lose--
so the sooner, the
better, I think.
Don't wait that your product
is perfect before you go.
Me, now, I invested in
many companies and I--
LINO CATTARUZZI: No,
that's comes after.
Don't talk about that.
LOIC DE KERDREL:
Yeah, some people
who wants to have something
perfect before go.
No, you go.
You go, and you repair on board.
You repair on board.
So that's my advice.
My advice as well would be to--
it was for me, very important
to share the experience
with someone.
You must have a
dream or a vision.
And you have to share it with
someone because it's very--
between the tough moment, if
you are alone, it's very--
it's a long journey.
So it's very tough to be alone.
Me, I could not have been alone.
So I have a very good friend.
He has--
LINO CATTARUZZI: You can
name him if you want.
LOIC DE KERDREL:
Yeah, Charles Costa.
He's a very good friend.
He has a very good
temper as well.
You have to share the
adventure with someone
who have the same value as you,
someone who will not kill you
for money, for example, or
someone who say, OK, this
is a bottle.
This is not an orange.
Because in some situation,
people say, no, sorry.
It's not a bottle.
It's an orange.
You have to share value
with your partner.
As well, for difficult moment,
it's nice to have a partner
and as well to share.
If you have the best moment, if
you're alone, it's quite sad.
So it's better to share.
And then after, if
you have a good team,
I would say the hard thing is
to get good people with you
on the boat, which is
not such a beautiful boat
at the beginning.
And you need to have
quality people along.
How do you get them?
Because you know that all the
best, they either go to Google
or set up their company.
So how do you do?
LINO CATTARUZZI: We
are happy with that.
We are happy they
come to Google.
LOIC DE KERDREL:
That's a big problem.
So how you do?
So you have to share your dream.
You have to be very enthusiastic
to make nice people come
on board with you.
And you have to
be nice to people
so that good people join
your adventure, basically.
LINO CATTARUZZI: I'm going
to ask you a little bit now
on your angel investments.
And then start thinking about
questions if you want to make.
And then I'll give
it to you guys.
So while you sold
the company, you
are still are the
CEO of the company.
But now, well, the bank
account is a little bit better.
And you are expanding
your reach now.
What is in your mind?
What are you doing?
How would you like to approach
future investments and things
like that?
LOIC DE KERDREL: Well,
it's a big question.
When you sell your company,
what am I going to do next?
And it's a big question.
And you're too young to retire.
You have not updated
your dreams because when
you create your company,
when you were 25--
I don't know-- maybe you dream
of going surfing on a beach
if you had enough
money to stop working.
When you sold your
company, you're nearly 40
and say, I don't want to go
anymore surfing on a beach.
Nobody is there.
So what--
[LAUGHTER]
LOIC DE KERDREL:
I'm too fat anyway.
So it's too late.
You have not
updated your dreams.
It's kind of a trauma.
So it's very hard
to re-adapt yourself
to what am I going to do.
So first, I started to
invest in companies.
But it's a bit frustrating
investing because you invest.
And it's like--
LINO CATTARUZZI: They
don't always give you money
LOIC DE KERDREL: No,
no, we were quite lucky.
I mean, I have invested.
One of my first investment
was sold to Google.
It was a company
called Moodstocks.
It was a visual
recognition software.
It was sold to Google.
So we had good adventures.
LINO CATTARUZZI: I had
nothing to do with that, guys,
by the way.
LOIC DE KERDREL: But
it's a bit frustrating
when you are an entrepreneur.
You want to lead your
own boat, basically.
And you don't want
to put money in--
it's like buying
a forest and wait
five years so the trees grow.
For me, it's not enough.
So I think I will
create something else.
I'm not sure exactly what.
But--
LINO CATTARUZZI: Well, I know
some of your side business
and your personal passions.
LOIC DE KERDREL: I had few
projects, actually, yes.
I have few project.
But for sure, I would start
again something, big or not,
but nice.
LINO CATTARUZZI: Guys, do
you have any questions?
LOIC DE KERDREL: I
hope you understood
what I said because--
[LAUGHTER]
LOIC DE KERDREL: --it
was a bit, you know.
LINO CATTARUZZI: No,
no, they have a chip.
It's Google translate.
So don't worry.
They've got everything.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
But maybe on your
current company.
You were saying that
you started making money
from other streams of--
getting other
streams of revenue.
How did [INAUDIBLE] that?
How is it working today?
Is it the main source of revenue
now that [INAUDIBLE] activity?
Or are you also still kind
of [INAUDIBLE] of AdSense?
Or how is it working today?
LOIC DE KERDREL: No, so
the advertising network
have changed.
We are not anymore
on the long tail.
We contract with big websites.
So we have moved from the
small websites to big websites,
basically.
So we have a more traditional
advertising network business.
Still, I would say, nearly half
of the business of the company.
But its a tough business
because now in France,
you have to be quite big.
We have 25 million
unique users in France.
And I would say it's the
minimum not to lose money.
The growth is quite low.
The microbilling is
still a good business.
But we have adapted it as
well because PayPal now
is everywhere.
LINO CATTARUZZI: You don't
need to call anymore.
LOIC DE KERDREL:
We have adapted it
to put more service
with the billing
because just billing, now big
companies are in this market.
So we try to put a layer
of service with a voice,
basically.
You guys are on
this market as well.
You are everywhere, huh?
But it's still a good business.
And I believe in billing
services through voice.
And publishing is still good.
And we have one website that
make the money for the others,
I would say.
We have a leader in--
societe.com is still
making good money.
Basically, we are selling--
LINO CATTARUZZI: Information.
LOIC DE KERDREL:
--information on companies,
financial information
on companies.
We buy raw information.
We clean it.
And we sell it in retail.
LINO CATTARUZZI: And
with Google [INAUDIBLE]..
I think a mic, yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much,
first of all to come here.
I want to [INAUDIBLE] what
are the things, the key things
that you are looking
at when you decide
to buy or to buy a stake
in a business very fast?
LOIC DE KERDREL: Well, I'm
not sure it's very rational,
I would say.
There's a large part
of instinct that I
feel through the exchange,
the talk with the founders.
And I invest very early stage.
So I would say knowing
the statistic is
you invest in 10 companies.
And one goes very well.
And most of the others
died, basically.
That's supposed
to be a statistic.
For us, it's not a statistic.
We are much better
than this because I
invest with my partner.
And we would say we have one
company, which is in difficulty
out of maybe 15 companies.
But most of them, they
are in good shape.
So I would say instinct of
the determination I have in--
LINO CATTARUZZI:
In the founders.
LOIC DE KERDREL:
--in the founders.
I would say it's the first--
it's my first key.
LINO CATTARUZZI: And
the business itself.
LOIC DE KERDREL: And of
course, the business,
you need to be in a
market that is coming.
I don't invest in where
there's no market,
basically, where it's too soon.
The time to market
is very important.
For us, for example,
we were very lucky
because of the time to market.
It was not a strategy.
It was luck, basically.
But two years before,
we would have died.
Two years after,
it was too late.
So the time to market
is very, very important.
But basically, the
profile of the founder
is very important because
you have to adapt all time.
If you have someone who is too
sure of where he wants to go,
it's not good because you
need people who are very fast,
who are ready to
change very fast,
can adapt their business
model very fast.
So I don't invest in people
who are too sure of themself,
basically, because you
need to be humble, I guess,
when you start a company.
Yeah, it's part of
instinct, I would say first.
And of course, I know a
bit of market as well.
I invest many on
internet businesses.
So I know--
LINO CATTARUZZI: A
lot of the ecosystem.
LOIC DE KERDREL: Few
things, few things-- and I
try to invest not on a
single person or businesses.
So I like to have at
least two partner.
Three partner is good.
I like a technical guy, a
business guy, and a design guy,
for example.
It's fantastic.
That's the best
typology, I would say.
I don't have my five
rules for investment.
I don't have this.
In five years, I
will have a good view
if I am a good investor or not.
For now, it's too soon.
We had two companies
that was sold already.
Good--
LINO CATTARUZZI: Multipliers.
LOIC DE KERDREL: Yes.
And I'm still optimistic
in most of them.
LINO CATTARUZZI: We'll bring
him back again in five years.
And then he will tell us.
LOIC DE KERDREL: Yes, yes.
I would come.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So what are the main
difference between entrepreneur
20 years ago and today in tech?
And do you think the
same entrepreneur
will have more chance of
success today or in the past?
LOIC DE KERDREL: OK, well,
it's a good question.
For me, it's much harder today
than 20 years ago because
20 years ago, there
was a big, big thing.
Internet was new.
So this disruption was so huge.
You don't find this
disruption today.
I mean, so even someone stupid
would jump into the water
and would follow the current
and would do something,
I would say.
It's a bit of a joke.
But it's not totally a joke.
If you were in the right moment,
now I find it very difficult.
Why?
Because all the smart
people going out
of big university,
big business school,
they all create companies.
They all read the
same newspaper.
LINO CATTARUZZI: Or
they work for Google.
LOIC DE KERDREL: Or
It's true.
I receive maybe 10
business plan every week--
people who want to raise money.
Quality of people is amazing.
The business plan are fantastic.
And so it's very
hard to find space.
You have so many bright
people, smart people
who create company today.
I mean, I'm sure they will
not all success for sure.
So I find it more difficult
now than 20 years ago
because you have
much more people.
And you don't have
such a big disruption.
Maybe I was saying
to Lino, I would
say abrupt change
is very interesting.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] .
LOIC DE KERDREL: Yeah,
abrupt change, for me,
is probably the big disruption
in my opinion, in my opinion.
But the other
disruption are extension
of previous disruptions, I
would say, like mobile or video
and all these.
But big companies
are already there.
You have to go.
It's very nice when
you go in a market--
not mature and a
bit chaotic, where
big companies,
big organization--
it's not easy for them to--
so I would say blockchain is
perfect for this, I would say.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
actually, my husband
was related to blockchain.
What do you think
about the whole--
people say it's a bubble.
Some people say it's
a new technology.
So what do you think about
the future of blockchain?
LOIC DE KERDREL: Well,
people had the same idea
with the internet.
Very smart, educated people told
me that internet is a bubble.
So I hear the same
with blockchain.
So I think, wow.
That's probably something good.
And that's why I want to
dig in this direction.
I think there is
something really--
I don't understand
very well blockchain,
to tell you the truth.
I don't understand
everything in blockchain.
But I feel that this is
something very, very disruptive
that will change
a lot of things,
like a new dimension of
business-- interesting,
I think,
AUDIENCE: Can I just--
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
This is more on a personal note.
But do you remember if you had
a moment where you thought,
OK, this is it.
I've made it.
I'm successful now, whether
it's founding a company
or selling it.
Or does it not work like that?
LOIC DE KERDREL: No,
and I have a problem
with the word "success."
Success for me is
something really weird.
I don't know if you have
read this in the newspaper.
You have Albert Einstein.
He wrote a note of paper
that was sold $1 million
in an auction yesterday
or the day before.
And it was a little word
on success and happiness.
And he said
basically that he had
found the secret of
happiness that it was not try
to find success at all price.
So success for me,
it's something--
so we had--
I don't really
feel I had success.
For me, success is to achieve
your goal, and try to be happy.
That's the only success you may
have in life, in my opinion.
So if you are lucky
to make your business
and to put it successful,
maybe develop it,
sold it, make money.
It's nice.
So it's kind of a success.
You have many little
success every day.
So I never had the idea of
having made the success.
For me, it was an obligation
to create my company
because I hate orders.
I don't like hierarchy
and this depends on it.
So I had no choice, basically.
[LAUGHTER]
LOIC DE KERDREL: So that's
why I created a new company.
So it was not a success.
It was a survival thing.
[LAUGHTER]
LOIC DE KERDREL: So in a
way, I survived, in a way.
LINO CATTARUZZI:
Oh, you did well.
You survived well.
LOIC DE KERDREL: No, my idea was
that we were lucky, very lucky.
I was saying, we
were very lucky.
It's not only luck.
But we were very lucky
in all the stories.
And I think I'm a
very lucky person.
But luck is, of course, being
rapid in grabbing opportunities
for sure.
So I grab opportunities
if I can, of course.
LINO CATTARUZZI: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So your
company has been
bought by the French "Poste."
LOIC DE KERDREL: Yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: So speaking about
change of culture and hierarchy
from owning your company to
being CEO of a company, which
has been bought by "La Poste"--
LOIC DE KERDREL: Yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: What do you--
LOIC DE KERDREL: No, it's a--
well, I negotiated, in the
deal, to keep my office
far from the office.
[LAUGHTER]
LOIC DE KERDREL: And it
was part of the deal.
They respected that.
LINO CATTARUZZI: I worry
that they watch this.
Or this is to
preserve the contract.
LOIC DE KERDREL:
No, no, I'm very--
and it's a big challenge
for companies to--
"La Poste," for example,
they want to, of course,
to have a digital
culture because they
have a big problem.
The stamps business, which is 20
billion euro turnover in France
is decreasing 10% a year.
Wow.
What do you do?
You have to find solutions.
The strategy is to buy
companies, digital companies
to prepare the future.
But how do you do?
They integrate that.
They have not, in my opinion,
answered this question.
And the fact that we're still
here, what's going to happen?
When we're going to leave?
Because the culture
is so different.
And we fight to keep
our culture, basically.
We fight to a certain
extent, basically.
We fight.
And we say, we think it's
a good idea to let us very,
very far from you if you
want to keep the good people.
They're going to leave if you
put too much hierarchy, too
much of processes.
LINO CATTARUZZI: But they
succeeded in this, right?
You still could have
your own culture.
LOIC DE KERDREL: They succeed.
But it's a big
challenge for them.
It's a big, big challenge
because I read something
about the L'Oreal
CEO today, who said
that digital culture come from
the ground, not from the top.
You can't say, I want my group
to have a digital culture now.
And you say, do it now.
It doesn't work like this.
It grows from the ground.
So big challenge, I would say.
But they're not too bad.
They're not too
bad in doing this.
LINO CATTARUZZI: Any
last questions, guys?
AUDIENCE: OK.
LINO CATTARUZZI: No?
If not, we're going to do
something very important.
We're [INAUDIBLE] Loic to be
a mentor for Google as well.
Thank you, Nicola,
for the T-shirt.
So we're going to give you one.
LOIC DE KERDREL: I
love that, you know.
Thank you very much.
LINO CATTARUZZI:
Next time he comes,
he can mentor a few startup
scene here in the MENA region.
LOIC DE KERDREL: I love Google.
I bought shares.
I love Google.
[INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
LINO CATTARUZZI:
Thank you so much.
LOIC DE KERDREL:
Thank you, Lino.